Of course, this is only a very coarse analysis actually
so you can have much better search trees and even for this tree here,
you can do a better analysis because actually,
this tree doesn't always have height K for the 3 cases that you branch in.
In one of the cases, as you'll remember,
you put 2 vertices into the vertex cover,
so this one here, this one here, and here you put 2.
Actually, that already decreases the size of the tree,
so doing this type of analysis is out of the scope of this course actually.
If you were to do this, then you find out that the size of the tree is
approximately 2.4 to the power of K.
And again, there are even better search trees for this.
The main point however is this,
look at what we have just done.
We have just discovered a search tree for a vertex cover
for which the size does not depend on the size of the input at all.
The size of this search tree only depends on the integer K.
It doesn't matter if we do it for a graph with 10 vertices, 100 vertices, or 1,000 vertices,
the size of the search tree only depends on K,
and it gets better if we implement this as an algorithm to solve vertex cover,
so the decision version of vertex cover.
Now look at this running time here and what that means.
The running time here will be
2.4 to the power of K times N to the power of some constant,
depending on how you implement it, but into the power of 3 will do here.